[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today to this's
question comes from Allen and
Pennsylvania he says Hey Y'all I've
recently seen companies advertising
cashback debit cards I'm in the process
of transitioning out of using a credit
card for day-to-day purchases my
question is how does a cashback debit
card work and where's the money coming
from uh that's a really good question
Dave I hear this a lot and a lot of
people have popped in saying Jade this
is a great way that I can build my
credit uh it's a debit card that will
report to the credit card companies or
you know report it on your credit report
but what they're not telling you is
you're still borrowing money no no the
the cash back credit card is just a like
a Rewards Card well the ones that I'm
looking at you're talking about the one
now
now Experian launched one that only
works with Experian boost and it reports
on the credit bureau right okay but this
is simply like discover has 1% back on
uh discover points or uh if you get
airline miles this it's a cash back
rewards all I don't have a problem with
that debit card um and where does the
money come from it comes from
transaction fees Merchant fees so we
don't accept credit cards on our website
because we tell people not to have them
and that would be hypocritical for me to
make money off of something I tell
people not to do okay so we take debit
cards on our website when you use your
debit card on our website we pay a
merchant fee a transaction fee most
cases I ours is different but because we
doesn't do a lot of volume but basically
it's around
3% okay so 100 bucks I pay 3% to the
merchant fee to transact the debit card
okay they can then take part of that fee
and give it back to you to get you to
use the debit card more because they
make money money when you use your debit
card they make transaction fees not off
of you but off of the merchant that you
are buying from same thing's true with
the credit card by the way yeah uh
credit card pays the exact same fees as
a matter of fact yeah uh Merchant fees
are exactly the same we don't pay less
or more because it's a debit card um
we've actually had to argue with a few
of these people that they wanted us to
they wanted to force us to accept credit
cards to get to process our transactions
no no no no that won't work can't do
business with you but um so a lot of a
lot of your uh uh the the credit card
companies don't just make money on the
interest M on your debt they also make
money on the transaction fees absolutely
and so when they're giving you airline
miles or whatever it's not just because
they're screwing you with 18% interest
it's also because the merchant
transaction fee is doing that and so
yeah I don't have a problem with it
let me tell you what the breakdown on
this is though the only issue it's the
wrong
question okay because you should not be
asking a question of I want to modify my
spending habits my method of payment in
order to get 1% yeah because that means
every time you spend a $100 you get a
dollar this is not for this is not going
to move the needle for you well and
somewhere in your brain you're going to
think oh if I spend more I'll get more
money and it's going to make you want to
spend can't spend your way into wealth
when you're trading a $100 expenditure
for a dollar cash back that's you just
lost 99 bucks on this okay yeah so uh I
mean this is so this is the the way that
these companies work though it's a
feedback loop and psychological feedback
loop and they're trying to keep you
spending and consuming because that's
where the transactions are where they
make all their money and so it's not
where you make all your money though and
when you're asking the question oh boy I
could get 1% back how about oh boy I'm
not going to spend a hundred bucks true
that and now I just made a hundred times
more money than even asking this
question aund times more money I Like It
by you know you know how you double your
money you fold it over once put it back
in your pocket right I mean that's it
that's quit
so don't let these people suck you
into trading a hundred for a dollar a
dollar for a penny don't don't make this
transaction and then walk around like
well I am very sophisticated I have a
cash back who gives a crap yeah you're
not sophisticated you're trading a 100
for one the focus is wrong yeah so it's
okay if you want to get cash back it's
not bad but the fact that you're even
worried about it is bad absolutely uh
since I wrongfully set myself up I feel
like we should talk about the other
thing too yeah okay the other thing is
there is now a debit card that does
report on your credit bureau yeah and it
is only with the Experian bank that's
the only one and it only works if it
only reports if you do Experian boost
now what Experian boost is is a fee that
you pay to the credit bureau reporting
company called Experian you pay them a
fee and they will boost your credit
rating
however those of you that have a boosted
rating need to know that no mortgage
company will use your boosted rating to
qualify you they will use your non
boosted rating and so you use your
Experian debit card you opened a bank
account with Experian so that they could
make these fees we were just talking
about so that you could pay them extra
to boost your credit while using their
debit card all to build a boosted score
that a mortgage company won't take
there's other ones too Dave that will
yeah there are the ones that they'll
give you they'll send you a card in the
mail and they'll say we will take a
portion of your paycheck and make it a
portion of your own money and make it
available to you as credit on this card
and so you spend let's say you spend
let's say you get paid $1,000 they'll
take $300 over and they'll say spend it
on this card and so they're but they're
fronting you the money first that's a
prepaid credit and then they'll come in
and whatever you spent for the month
they'll come in and they'll take it out
of your account yeah but that that is
actually debt yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah yeah that's actually debt
that's a prepaid credit card this but
they call them debit cards they're
calling them that erroneously it it is
not the technical it can't a debit card
does not count on on your credit score
that's right period okay unless you run
it through Boost but the uh um not as of
right now anyway so yeah prepaid credit
cards back in the day had huge fees on
them I suspect that does I haven't seen
that product um and it was mainly being
used by um poor people yeah lower income
people it's like you know same people
shop at the pawn shop and think they're
going to get rich off a lotto MH it's
the same poor people and that's why
they're poor and it's one of the reasons
they're poor anyway yeah and uh Dave
Ramsey hates the poor Now Dave Ramsey
works his whole life so that you're not
poor I spent all of my time helping you
not be poor I want you to not do poor
people's stuff and that way you're not
poor okay and poor people stand in line
the number one ZIP codes that buy lotto
tickets are poor
neighborhoods by far the vast majority
of lotto tickets purchased are in poor
neighborhoods so I'm not making that up
I mean it's an actual data point and
it's not a moral judgment it's just
going hey how's that working for you you
know it's the same neighborhood that has
title Pond Tote The Note lot and rent to
own washer and dryer for God's sakes
that you could buy for 50 bucks at a
garage sale but instead you pay 2,000
bucks for it rent to owning it but this
is all short-term thinking thank God
it's Friday oh God it's Monday and
that's where the prepaid credit card
shows up is in that environment it's
also paid lenders in that neighborhood
and um what is these commercials God
they're awful cash advanced Place well
it's payday lenders it's cash advance
but uh just horrendous and the interest
rates with the payday lenders
800%
800% now you want to find somebody
that's picking on poor people it's those
people that are picking on poor people
they're they're making a good living
getting rich off the backs of poor
people when you charge po people 800%
and by the way rich people don't pay
that they don't play that and they those
those things aren't in the rich
neighborhood they're not even in middle
class
neighborhoods you know it's your lotto
tickets it's these it's a shortterm
it'll kill you guys it'll kill you don't
fall for it don't fall for it don't fall
for it don't fall for it just go make
some money live on less than you make in
stack cash this is the Ramsey Show